Speaker 1: We have very, very bad news for
Republican Congressman Matt Gaetz.
We have now heard that Matt Gaetz was told
Matt, you had sex with a minor.
She's under 18.
The broader context here is this investigation
that's now been going on for we've known about
it for about 10 months into Republican Trumpian
Congressman Matt Gaetz, who is being investigated
for a whole bunch of different things, including
possibly having sex with a minor.
Sometimes we call that statutory rape trafficking,
sex trafficking of a minor across state lines,
potentially paying people for sex.
There's all these different things.
He's denied everything and has lawyered up
with some of the best sex crimes defense attorneys
and one of the questions has been.
Is he sort of like a bystander here and he
wasn't ever even really told, Hey, some of
the stuff you're doing might not be OK.
There is an incredible blockbuster piece of
information now, as the Daily Beast is reporting,
witness can confirm, Matt Gates was told he
had sex with a minor.
One of the key interactions Joel Greenberg
this is like his wingman claims to have had
with Matt Gates, is a phone call informing
Gates they'd been sleeping with a minor.
Someone witnessed the call, meaning it is
not only Greenberg that says this call took
place.
There's a witness that now corroborates it.
Here's the detail.
On September four, 2017, according to his
confession letter, Joel Greenberg called his
friend Matt Gaetz with some bad news.
The teenager both men paid to have sex with
was underage.
Greenberg claimed now, two sources tell The
Daily Beast, a cooperating witness can confirm
details of that call for one damning reason
he was in Greenberg's office when the call
took place.
The witness, Big Joe Ellicott, Greenberg's
longtime best friend and an employee at the
Seminole County Tax Office, recently pleaded
guilty to fraud and drug charges as part of
a cooperation agreement.
Although Ellacott has so far avoided charges
regarding sex trafficking of a minor, which
Greenberg pleaded guilty to last May, he was
present for the call that Greenberg made to
Gates on September 4th, according to two people.
The call, they said, was short, and Gates
was the one who ended it.
This, and here is the specifics.
Immediately, I called the congressman and
warned him to stay clear of this person and
informed him she was under age.
Gates was equally shocked and disturbed.
There was no further contact with this individual.
Until after her 18th birthday, that this is
just absolutely incredible.
Now, of course, investigators aren't stupid.
They are going to look at phone records and
I'm sure already have to see if there is such
a call that took place between Greenberg and
Gates on September 4th of 2017.
But we now have a witness to the call, Greenberg
and the witness both are saying this call
took place and this is looking worse and worse
for Matt Gaetz.
Now do we know if charges will be brought?
No, we don't know that a lot of this comes
to what can you prove?
Do we know whether there were other such instances
where Gates was repeatedly told about the
underage reality of this woman?
We just don't have all of the information,
but what do we know?
We are 10 months in and the investigation
hasn't ended.
Gates's wingman is cooperating and has pleaded
guilty.
There is a cooperation agreement for another
individual associated with the entire thing,
and there are now specific assertions being
made that it wasn't just that it just so happened
that this is what took place with Gates.
Gates was told that this is what took place.
So if I had to guess this isn't going away
anytime soon.
And specifically, if and when what particular
charges will be brought against Gates, we
just don't know.
We'll have a link to this article and more
information on our Instagram, which you can
find at David Pakman.
You can also follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman.